good morning John I was watching a video
yours that you made a couple weeks ago
and I noticed something that maybe
remember something so in this video you
pointing out that Willie had chewed the
arm off of Chewbacca and I remembered
something somewhat strange about myself
I used to be a bit of a connoisseur of
Star Wars and removal you know hands
getting chopped off in Star Wars movies
and there are a lot of hands removed in
fact there are characters in the Star
Wars universe who only have two hands
who have their hands chopped off three
times I mean this has to be a metaphor
for something Chewbacca was always
supposed to be written people's arms out
of their sockets but he never actually
did it and he also managed to keep both
of his hands throughout the entire
series of movies so it was a big deal
for me when I saw the two Baca had
finally lost an arm anyway I've decided
that for today's video I'm gonna walk
you through every single Star Wars hand
removal of a major character in the
movies there are more and minor battle
scenes and of course if you go into the
book stand you've got a lot more to deal
with now unlike some Star Wars purists I
consider the prequels to be Star Wars
movies so let us go chronologically the
first Star Wars movie the Phantom Menace
arguably the worst live-action Star Wars
movie ever
all hands stayed attached to bodies
obviously this is a bad movie now Attack
of the Clones that was a much better
movie and why well it starts out with a
hand removal jerk in a bar with a gun
gets their hand chopped off by obi-wan
Kenobi something that Iran don't mess
with a Jedi then later comes the second
hand removal of the Star Wars trilogy of
that of Anakin Skywalker by Count Dooku
mmm a theme that you will start to
recognize is that when someone cuts
someone's hand off at Star Wars there's
a good chance that they're gonna get
their hand chopped off too and that's
what happens at the beginning of Revenge
of the Sith
Count Dooku who has just recently cut
off Anakin Skywalker's first hand gets
both of his hands chopped off shortly
before being killed completely and this
is when things really peak for Star Wars
hand removal Revenge of the Sith very
good movie lots of hands getting chopped
off this has helped along by the fact
that General Grievous has not two but
four hands unfortunately and this always
sort of made me angry he only loses two
of them if you're gonna give somebody
four hands you might as well cut off all
four then thus it come back to payback
the Jedi for cutting off all those SIF
hands and mace windu gets his arm
chopped off by Anakin Skywalker it's
worth noting that now Anakin Skywalker
has chopped off three hands just in this
one movie and he's only had one hand cut
off so you probably know it's about to
happen
Anakin Skywalker goes all
Elwin kenobi has only one choice which
is to cut off both of his legs and yes
one of his hands and so not only anakin
skywalker only has one hand and it's
robotic moving on to the actual Star
Wars movies the first one a new hope
c-3po gets his arm yanked off by a
Tuscan Raider you don't see it happen
but you do see the arm lay in there on
the ground and then obi-wan cuts off his
second gun wielding arm in a bar and
Natalie must discuss Empire Strikes Back
would of course has the most famous hand
removal probably in all of history we
can't talk about that until we recognize
the giant snow beast who captured Luke
Skywalker hung him upside down in the
cave and then got his arm chopped off
why did Luke do it why did he chop off
that hand because you know now Luke's
gonna get his hand chopped off and then
one of the most memorable scenes in all
of science fiction possibly all of movie
history Luke Skywalker gets his hand
chopped off Luke Skywalker gets a bionic
hand just like it's dear old dad and we
move on to return the Jedi in which
there is only one hand removal Luke
Skywalker gets his revenge and chops off
Darth Vader's third hand oddly enough if
you also read the comic books and the
books Darth Vader has his hands chopped
off no less than five times Luke looks
down and realized this it's just a bunch
of wires and then feels his own Bionic
hand and they reconcile or something
whatever more stuff happens but no more
hands get chopped off so as far as I'm
concerned that's the end of the movie
pinna Jedi sounds cool and all but way
too dangerous a lot of work for me and
now you know your life is going to be so
much better now that you have this
information john dftba
you